god is good
and all the time let's try that again
god is good and all the time
yes psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord
is good that was one of the
characteristics that he demonstrated to
moses
uh when moses said show me thy glory in
exodus 33 verse 18
and in chapter 34 verse 6 a god showed
abundantly goodness
god is a good god
and i often say every blessing in my
life
every good thing in my life has come
from god
every problem i have brought on myself
and so i publicly clear the name of god
from any wrongdoing in my life
god has never ever
done me anything wrong
never if i were to burn in hell tomorrow
with my last breath i would say the same
thing you
have never done me anything
wrong so i thank god
for being fair just merciful
and gracious to me long suffering to a
degree
i do not understand god's mercy towards
me
seems to be eternally elastic
just stretches endlessly what else can i
do
then make sure that the rest of my life
is lived
for the glory of god and that somehow
others may be blessed by what i do and
so i say again god is good
and all the time let me see what time it
is
it is now oh three or five
you look pleasant you also look tired
so i will not delay you very long three
or five i shall let you out by
oh no no no no no no no
no six sister if six o'clock comes and
someone's in this desk he may look like
me but it won't be me
so maybe a quarter to four something
like that okay
can you turn off your phones please
you know how hard this feather is
we are so addicted to the phone it is
hard when a preacher says please
turn your phones off for 45 seconds
people start going into withdrawals
please
please turn your phones
off until they are dead
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put what your words where
in that man's mouth and god knows i mean
that
and favor number three i want you to
think
as you listen somebody come and pray for
me
someone who loves the lord believes in
the church
looking for the coming of christ come
and pray for me nice short prayer
come anyone fits those three
descriptives
loves the lord believes in the church as
god's people
and is preparing for the coming of
christ come
could someone put life in one of these
things
all right here we go my handsome brother
here you are
heads bowed eyes closed
please father send thy holy spirit speak
through your manservant right now
hide him behind the cross of calvary and
do not allow him to speak
one word from his own mind or
speak through him mightily
and that we will hear the message you
want each of us to hear
give us a teachable spirit that we will
leave this place
change by the message you speak
through your manservant and that people
will see christ
in us thank you for answering this
prayer
in jesus name amen amen amen
thank you god what's your name my
brother
jake elgin jenkins
eldon jenkins god bless you brother
jenkins and your family
and grant all of you a place in his
kingdom when he comes
thank you very much matthew 24 reading
from verse 3.
excuse me what book did i say what
chapter
what is chapter 24 of matthew famous for
the signs of the times what chapter does
the same thing in mark
13 what chapter in luke does the same
thing
21. what chapter and john does the same
john doesn't have one all right matthew
reading from verse 3. do you have that
and as he sat upon the mount of olives
the disciples came unto him privately
saying
tell us when shall these things be
and what shall be the sign of thy coming
and of the end
of the world and jesus now notice what
they said
when shall these things be first
question
what shall be the sign of thy coming
second question
and of the end of the world but christ
did not
answer any of those first
he gave an answer that they needed
more than the answers they sought
so when nicodemus said in john chapter 3
rabbi
we know that thou were to teach us sent
from god for no one can do these
miracles which thou doest except god be
with him
jesus said verily verily i say unto you
except
a man be born again of water he cannot
enter the kingdom of god or see it
now god gave nicodemus an answer he was
not looking for
and so the disciples said when shall
these things be
what shall be the sign of thy coming and
of the end of the world the first four
and jesus answered and said unto them
take
heed finish the verse that
no man deceive you
now the word man there's generic it
means no
being should deceive you
not your wife
not your husband not your boyfriend
not your boss not your pastor
not even an angel from heaven
now you say why do you why do i say that
what does paul say for though we
are an angel from heaven preach any
other gospel unto you
than that which we have preached unto
you let him be a curse
jesus said take heed now that sounds
suspiciously like what
watch our theme watch
now the bible is clear in the end time
one of the deliberate activities
practiced against the church is
deception
for i know this that after my departing
shall grievous wills enter among you
not sparing the flock also of your own
selves
shall men arise speaking perverse
things
and so jesus said take heed be on your
toes
be alert that no ma'am
deceive you verse 5 for many shall come
in my name saying i
am christ and shall deceive
many
keep this in mind many shall come into
my name saying i'm christ
and shall deceive many matthew 24 5.
listen to revelation 12 9 just listen
don't go there
and the great dragon was cast out not
all serpent called the devil and satan
which deceiveth the whole
world
listen to 2nd thessalonians 2 from verse
3.
take heed let no man deceive you for
that day shall not come
except they come of falling away first
and that man of sin be revealed the son
of perdition
who exalteth and opposes himself against
all that is called god
or that is worship so that he is god
sitteth
in the temple of god showing himself
that he is god
now the man of sin of course the
antichrist you call it the bible has
several references
the little horn of daniel 7 you know the
the the leopard-like beast of revelation
13 the bible says
in verse 3 2nd thessalonians 2
let no man deceive you by any means
combine
paul and christ christ said take heed
that no man deceive you paul says let no
man deceive you by
any means
we are warned to be on our toes
then the question becomes what can i do
to protect myself from deception
now bear in mind deception is the work
of the devil
he uses agents but he is the power
behind deception
god is the power behind truth we're
dealing
with the two greatest powers in the
universe the power of god
the power of satan but satan has an edge
because we are born with a carnal nature
are you with me we are born with a
nature
that hates the law of god and the law of
god is truth
romans 8 verse 7 because the carnal mind
is enmity against god
for it is not subject to the law of god
the bible says thy law is truth
the law of truth was in his mouth the
bible tells us
and so deception
if we are not careful even the converted
person can be caught
that's why i ask again what is the
protection
against deception because deception
that's coming
is subtle
are you with me you read allah's
writings on the
rebellion of satan or lucifer in heaven
how was lucifer able to deceive
perfect angels with amazing minds
now when the devil was thrown out of
heaven he lost
his position not his power
the power with which he deceived then is
greater now
because he has had thousands of years to
perfect his craft
listen to me carefully you cannot
win an argument with the devil
i gave you a quotation earlier bible
commentary volume 5
page 10 83 paragraph one bear in mind
that it is none but god that can hold an
argument with satan only god
not gabriel and not i and with great
respect
not you
if that's the case we need a resource
that is divine
we need a form of immunization
against the virus of deception we need
an immunization
that is not of this earth and that
immunization is this
this is your protection and mind
from deception as we watch and
we pray
take heed that no man deceive you
the word of god is not fully appreciated
among god's people as it should
but if you study the bible carefully
you'll discover
that this word of god is perhaps the
most amazing thing in the entire
universe you know god does everything
through his word
and i say everything and i've preached
this many times
he creates through the word he sustains
creation
through the word he saves through the
word
he sanctifies through the word
he heals through the word he cast out
demons
to the word he forgives through the word
he shows us right and wrong through the
word he exposes our fundamental motives
through the word the word is so elevated
in the estimation of god
that jesus christ is called the word of
god
the bible says in psalm 138 verse 2 that
god has magnified his word above
all his name
there are 300 names for god in the bible
all telling us a little more about god
god's word
is by god's own action magnified
above all his name
it is not by accident the bible opens
with a series of statements and god said
and god said and god
said over and over and over we know from
second timothy
chapter 3 verse 16 all scripture is
given now
by inspiration of god and is profitable
for doctrine
for reproof for correction for
instruction in righteousness
there must be an instructional reason
why the bible tells us and god said
and god said and god said
over and over as if god was trying to
nail it into our skulls
this this
is our power this is our strength
this is our light this is our path
this is our protection from deception
in the book evangelism
page 138 paragraph four what book did i
say
what paragraph what page
all right i was trying to confuse you i
failed
all right but i'm trying to prepare you
for the devil
okay listen to what i know i says the
word of god
is our sanctification and righteousness
because it is spiritual food
to study it is to eat the leaves of the
tree of life
what did the tree of life provide for
adam and eve
well no question can be easier than that
what is the tree of life
provide for adam and eve life
now are we supposed to have life now
when we accept christ
yes or no yes
how the word
the words that i speak unto you they are
spirit
and they are life listen to me carefully
when you accept the word of god
by faith you believe it the life of god
enters you through god's word
thank you what did i just say
when we accept god's word through faith
the life of god enters us
through the word when jesus says in john
6 63
the words that i speak unto you they are
spirit and their life
what life do you think he meant the very
yes his life whoever said that god bless
you his life
education page 126 paragraph four
this the creative energy that called
the worlds into existence is in the word
of god
this word begets power it imparts life
every command is a promise accepted by
the will
received into the soul it brings with it
the life of the infinite one who is the
infinite one god
this brings the life of god to us
don't ask me how when i breathe i don't
stop to think how the oxygen gets from
my lungs to the bloodstream i don't
think
i don't think to stop the thing how the
carbon oxide carbon monoxide leaves the
blood
and gets to my lungs and exits my
nostrils or mouth i don't ask
i just let it happen
we always want god to give us scientific
explanations why we shouldn't eat the
pig don't eat it
and so jesus says the words that i speak
unto you
they are spirit they are life
bible commentary volume 1 page 286
paragraph 5 she writes these words
the scriptures it is written is the
gospel
we are to preach no flaming sword
is placed before this tree of life
so she equates this with the same power
found in the tree of life
let me give you the words again the
scriptures
it is written is the gospel we are to
preach
no flaming sword is placed
before this tree of life all who will
may partake of it there is no power that
can prohibit
any soul from taking of the fruit of
this tree of life all may eat and live
forever
you know jesus said in john 6 26
he that leaveth and believeth in me
shall never die
and that's true you can only believe on
christ
through the word
i keep getting these isolated events
which i'm profoundly grateful
but i'm getting the impression that most
of you are not understanding what i'm
saying
i may have to stay till six until
somebody
jesus said he that liveth and believeth
in me
shall never die
clearly that never die means that
eternal death
when you die in christ you die
with the seed of the living word in you
are you listening to me don't ask me to
explain the word of god is life
when you die in christ you die
with a spark of life in you
and that life will answer to the voice
of christ
my brothers and sisters this
is the antidote for deception
i told you yesterday there is a way that
seemeth right unto a man listen to the
words microscopically
there is a way that seemeth what
right from every angle your
intended action is right
but it is really wrong
now how do you detect the difference
this
if people studied the word of god
honestly
they would not worship the way they
worship
let me speak with respect do you know
there is not one bible verse
that calls the first day of the week
holi
do you know that in 2
000 years since the death of christ or
the life of christ
up to today no one has found one
bible verse authorizing the first day of
the week
as a holy day not one
and yet the entire world virtually
observes the first day of the week
now listen now to revelation 12 9 and
the great dragon was cast out
that old serpent called the devil and
satan which deceiveth
the whole world
you can go to church as long as you like
you can hold all the offices you like
if you have no time for this you have no
time for god
let me say it again
i thank god for saying through jesus
take heed that no man deceive you
we do not understand rejection of god's
word is rejection of god
now you don't have to reject god by
saying i reject you
you simply have to be too busy
no time for this that is rejection of
god
rejection of truth is rejection of the
author of truth
and so when god told saul go destroy the
amalekites first samuel 15.
when he did not do as god said samuel
told in verse 23
because thou has rejected the word of
the lord
he has also rejected thee
when we make no time for god's word
understand what i'm saying
we have no time for god we may have time
for church
but we have no time for god the
pharisees and the scribes they had time
for church
they had no time for god
the bible says in second peter chapter 3
verse 18
grow in grace how and in the knowledge
of our lord and savior jesus christ
outside of this you cannot grow in grace
i'll ask you a question don't answer me
do you study the bible don't answer me
i mean have you ever decided you know
i'm a seventh-day adventist
i've been one for decades i cannot
defend the sabbath
let me call the pastor
and in this modern age even he can't
defend it
you know i've been an adventist all my
life how can i biblically show a
vegetarian diet as optimal as best
i can't do it
i've been an adventist all my life i
can't defend the state of the dead
i've been an adventist all my life i do
not know the ten commandments from
memory
not even the fourth
i've been an adventist all my life i do
not know
the three angels messages
i've been an adventist for decades i've
held
offices including elder treasurer
whatever other influential office the
church offers us
and i cannot defend the church
so i just do it because my friends do it
and i'm accustomed to the lifestyle so i
follow it
my brothers and sisters i do not mean to
rebuke you that's not my intention
we're all children of god we all need to
grow in grace
but the worst form of deception is
self-deception
a decent life is not the same thing as a
save life
alawite rights i believe it's great
controversy page 549 paragraph two
someone can check it on you or whatever
many a man of polished
culture education polish intellect and
cultured manners
who would not stoop to commit what is
commonly regarded as an immoral act
is but a polish instrument in the hands
of satan
here's a man would not commit an act of
immorality
well educated well spoken well-cultured
knows how to dress for the occasion how
to use a knife and fork
an instrument of satan
i think i'm sure it's great controversy
509 paragraph two
is it all right so what am i saying
we need to look closely at our lives
the devil deceives unfallen angels
the devil deceived samuel
when he picked eliab as god's choice for
king
and he was wrong clearly it was not the
holy ghost
because the holy ghost doesn't guide you
incorrectly it was not the spirit of god
that told samuel she was elia it was the
spirit of the enemy
it was the devil that got into peter
in matthew 16 from 21-23
and in verse 23 then peter took him and
began to rebuke him saying be it far
from the lord
this shall not be unto thee but he
turned and said unto him get thee behind
me satan
for thou art an offense unto me for thou
savorists not the things that be of god
but those that be of man what jesus was
saying peter
your mind is on this earth that's why
you were trying to frustrate the gospel
peter was trying to stop the plan of
salvation
with the best of intentions
that's the that's the deadly thing about
error and deception
people follow it with the best of
intentions
and here's peter close to christ telling
christ don't go and die
in other words don't save the world
don't carry out the everlasting compact
made between the father and the son
from way back don't do that but peter
did not know what he was saying
because his mind was rooted on the earth
and jesus said
you're telling me that and he said get
behind me satan
by the way in a moment you can be an
instrument of the devil
for five seconds your child of god
standing right next to god
and for five seconds your guard is
dropped you're an instrument of the
devil
not a child of the devil an instrument
you didn't hear what i said
jesus turned and said get thee behind me
satan talking to peter because
jesus realized in those words
peter represented satan but peter would
have sworn he was looking out for the
best interest of jesus
and so you decide to join the church and
your husband tries to stop you
thinking of your best interests and your
mental health
a child wants to join the church the
parents tries to stop him
because they're not enlightened by the
word of god let me
close and make an appeal
jesus said take heed that no man deceive
you
this is how you take heed
now since we're in the last days
our behavior must be different from
those who did not live in the last days
let me explain what i mean you're
sitting comfortably
we'll have the closing prayer and then
you'll walk out casually
if the police run in and say listen
there's some terrorists heading this way
with machine guns and they're killing
everybody
you would not get up and say okay okay
thanks you would run
because you're living in the end time
you understand you would run
because circumstances will change the
way you behave
if you're in the supermarket and the the
announcement comes over there's a fire
now we're in the last days how should we
behave
the deceptions of the devil in these
last days
will be so great
that only the minds purified
cleansed and enlightened by the word of
god
will detect the error
that will masquerade as truth
how does that happen let's go to hebrews
chapter 5
then i'll close hebrews 5.
here's what the bible says before we go
to hebrews five
let's go to a couple of books to the
right of hebrews let's go to first peter
chapter two we shall read verse two
what does first peter chapter 2 verse 2
say
as newborn babes go on desire what
the sincere milk of the word
that ye may grow thereby now is there a
legitimate place for milk in the life of
the christian yes or no
yes
how many of you have been in the
adventist church 20 years maybe you'll
have
20. don't be ashamed raise your hands
20. all right 30.
40. 15.
okay that's a long time are you still
drinking milk
if you are i'm no prophet but if you are
you will be deceived
now having said that let's go to hebrews
chapter 5.
we read from verse 11
paul is writing to the church
wherever that hebrews congregation was
speaking of jesus christ he says in
verse 11
of whom we have many things to say but
hard to be uttered
seeing you a dull of hearing for when
for the time
he ought to be teachers you have nade
that won't teach you again
wish me the first principles of the
oracles of god and i become such as have
need of milk and
not strong meat now paul
is complaining paul is rebuking what
paul is saying
all those of you who raise your hands to
say you've been in the church
30 years 40 years 20 years
you should be teaching others
but you still need milk
verse 13 for everyone that uses milk is
what
unskillful finish the verse in the word
of
righteousness now he's referring to
mature christians
still drinking milk he is not referring
to what peter talked about
as newborn babes someone got baptized
last month maybe last year
there are too many milk drinkers in the
church
now verse 14 of hebrews 5. do you have
it
read my version with me but strong meat
belonging to them that are what foolish
even those who by
reason of use have their senses
exercised to do what
discern good and evil
now the key word is discern
give me five more minutes is that okay
the key word
is discern discern is different from
c let me explain what i mean
here come two young people to the pastor
or the youth leader
we want to do missionary work we want to
do bible work one is nineteen one is
seventeen
one is a man once a woman the pastor
says oh good good good good why don't
you go out on sundays
for three hours and knock on doors and
he sends them out 19 year old man
17 year old girl or 19 year old man 19
year old girl
woman what he does not discern
is that when people work together and
they're not careful
things happen at another level of which
they are not aware
are you listening to me
and so he sends them out with the best
of intentions
to win the world for christ and several
months later
had no discernment
the power of discernment allows you not
only to see what something is
but what it can lead to ah you missed it
you keep missing everything i say
let me say it again listen to me
carefully the power of discernment
allows you to see not only what
something is
but what it can lead to
and so paul says but strong meat belong
after them that are of full age
those of you in the church for 20 years
15 25
30 40 50 100 full age even those
who by reason of use
how often how often should you use your
mind
every day have this senses
exercise finish the verse to discern
what both good do you know how many
christians can't discern evil
how many times have you heard christians
say what's wrong with that
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
dancing
what's wrong with the movies if you pray
first what's wrong with the
alcohol on your birthday what's wrong
with you on miniskirt
what's wrong with the non-adventist
boyfriend what's wrong with another out
of his girlfriend
what's wrong with you know dancing in
the church what's wrong with going
swimming on the beach on the sabbath
what's wrong with fishing on the sabbath
we cannot see what's wrong with anything
and why we're still on milk
remember this by now rancid
my brothers and sisters
present truth is not baptism by
immersion
did you know what i said when you talk
about present truth you don't talk about
baptism by immersion any other church
can preach that
present truth is not jesus came and died
present truth the three angels messages
now that's not milk what's that that's
meat
i don't want you to listen to those
preachers on television but
if you think you're strong enough doing
it do a study
and listen to a few of them prayerfully
you will never hear
a message of the three angels from any
other person's mouth in the seventh
athens
because they don't know how to preach it
because it was given to a special people
now
what am i saying present truth the three
angels messages
present truth daniel 8 14. president
truth
daniel 9 24-27 present truth the
the the divinity of christ present truth
the humanity of christ
present truth the possibility of total
victory over sin
present truth the perpetuity of god's
law present truth
the central role of the sabbath present
truth
the relation between christ and the law
not baptism by immersion
now when you study those subjects that
is meat
that is what clarifies your thinking
opens your eyes
to show you error like the 2520
error like keeping the feast
error like the holy ghost is not equal
to the father in divinity
like offshore churches are god's people
they're not
because god doesn't have two people
all kinds of error that seem attractive
are accepted because we do not
exercise the mind to discern both good
and evil truth is good error is evil my
brothers my sisters
let me bring an end to what seems like
an eternal rebuke
let me tell you something i want you to
believe i want
every one of you saved
no one is saved in error
you made a decision earlier today to try
to bring one soul to christ
that's very serious last defense page
282 paragraph three
elo white writes there will be no one
saved in heaven with a starless crown
if you enter there will be some soul in
the courts of glory
that has found an entrance there through
your instrumentality
listen to me again listen why no one
will enter heaven who has not been
responsible directly or indirectly
for the salvation of someone else she
also says
in councils on health page 287 paragraph
three
everyone who fails to obtain the victory
carries others down through his
influence
which means every human being will
either take some other human being to
heaven
or to hell
let me give it to you again councils on
health page 287
paragraph three everyone who fails
to obtain the victory carries others
down
through his influence in other words
every lost
person will be responsible for someone
else
being lost without exception and every
saved person
will be responsible for someone else
being saved
you choose on what side you stand
are you going to save someone when you
don't know the method of salvation
and so i said while you made a
commitment to lead
one soul to christ
between february 20 was this 22nd
2015 and february 22 2016.
you need a more foundational commitment
study this
councils for the church page 207
paragraph 6 alawite rights
as a means of intellectual training
the bible is more effective than any
other book
or all other books combined
and for those of you in college
university who think bible study is a
waste of time you spend all your time in
physics
my character and personality volume 1
page 34 paragraph 2
as in the case of daniel in
exact proportion as the spiritual
character is developed
the intellectual capabilities are
increased
now she's speaking almost like a
statistician in exact
proportion as the spiritual
character is developed this is what
develops it the intellectual
capabilities
so as you grow in god's way you grow
intellectually because god manages both
i want you to pair your commitment to
bring one soul to christ
with a commitment to study god's word
this is the more important one and don't
tell dr tim i said that
are you with me because you can lead
someone to christ and be a cast away
and the bible doesn't want that but if
you're
faithful in your life and this is the
only means of instruction as to what a
faithful life is
that life will be responsible for
someone else entering the kingdom
i want you to make a commitment right
now father
every day i will take
even if it's 10 minutes let's start
small and that's a principle from god
luke 16 10 he that is faithful in that
which is least
is faithful also in much now if you
faithfully give god
10 minutes in the morning and 10 at
night i said faithfully
you will extend that to 15. then 20
then 25 because he grows sweeter
and sweeter every day
and so i publicly
recommit my life to the proclamation
of truth
i state publicly i believe
that christ is my savior
but he can't force salvation on me it's
a work of cooperation
that is clear in john 3 16 for god so
loved the world
we did not have to tell him anything he
just loved us he gave his only begotten
son we did not have to tell him anything
he just gave
that whosoever believeth that's my part
i believe the sacrifice of christ which
includes his difficult life
his sinless life his voluntary death his
glorious resurrection all of that
the sacrifice of christ is sufficient
to cover all my sins on the basis of
that
i can go to god for forgiveness for
anything else i need remove that
sacrifice god can do
nothing for me nothing
i believe that christ and the father are
equal
and so does the holy ghost i believe
god has a people on this earth
who speaks for him because they speak
biblically
any church that does not speak
does not speak for god and since there
are only two authorities
when you do not speak for god you're
speaking for satan
i believe that there's a power
available for me to overcome sin one day
not only a power available i believe it
is required
now unto him that is able to keep you
from falling
and to present you how faultless
i believe there is a day of worship that
has never changed
the day is the seventh day it begins at
sunset
it ends at sunset it has never
changed i believe god has a standard of
righteousness
called the ten commandments i believe
that the ten commandments reflect
express in a way we can understand the
very
character of god
i believe there are beings called angels
that protect us
and help us understand the word even as
gabriel was sent with a command
make this man to understand the vision
angels help us
understand the word i believe when a
person dies the person is in the grave
awaiting the voice of the life-giver
either to come up to get your final
punishment
or come up to get your eternal reward
i believe god has a remnant
people to whom he gave a specific name
testimonies volume 1 page 2 23 paragraph
i was shown in regard to the remnant
people of god taking a name
two classes were presented before me the
first class
made up of the professed christians they
were trampling upon god's law
and bowing to a papal institution they
were keeping the first day of the week
as a sabbath of the lord
the other class who were but few in
number were bowing to the great law
giver
they were keeping the fourth commandment
the peculiar and prominent
features of the faith were observance of
the seventh day
and waiting for the appearing of our
lord from heaven
i believe christ is coming back
sooner than we think
and i believe before he comes there will
be
a time of trouble such as never worth
since there was a nation even at that
same time
and to survive that time of trouble that
never has been
we need a level of spiritual development
that
never has been
the spiritual power that god knower
through the flood
will not be enough to get god's people
to the time of trouble
this is the source studied
and obeyed what did i say
studied and obeyed
i said 10 minutes in the morning 10 at
night now here's what you do
pick a bible verse i recommend the
gospel of john
start at john 1 1 go to john 21
in the beginning was the word and word
was with god
and the word was god you stop then you
start talking to god father
what does that mean now you may get no
answer until you get to verse 14 you
understand
but you try you keep moving you go to
verse two the same was in the beginning
with god who is the same must refer to
somebody in verse 1.
verse 3 all things were made by him and
without him was not anything made that
was made
now you have a clue as to who him is now
him is one of two because verse 1 says
in the beginning was the word the word
was with god the word was god so we have
two
all things were made by him so one of
the two is the identified creator
verse 4 her name was life and the life
was the light of men
and you think you say father what does
this mean
now as you engage your mind
with this you wrestle something will
happen to your mind
not overnight but surely gradually and
gradual doesn't mean slow it means
piece by piece
you do that then you pray
take those thoughts with you during the
day that night you come back
see if anything came to you during the
day in the beginning was the word the
word was with god the word was god
father
i'm still wrestling that's fine exercise
for the mind rustle
then you do it go to bed by the way
the last thing on your mind at night
should be the word of god not something
your husband told you
let me clarify before i'm arrested if
your husband or your wife tells you
something that's
then you take a bible verse and say it
are you with me because the devil
attacks us during the night
your protection is god's word so no
matter what your spouse tells you or
your brother who sleeps next to you or
whomever
you say fine fine yes yes then you
quietly say a bible verse to cover your
mind
let the last thing on your mind
be the word of god
you go to sleep you wake up in the
morning
you go to verse 5 and the light shineth
in darkness and the darkness
comprehended it not what does that mean
there was a man sent from god whose name
was john what does that mean well that
sounds easy okay john the baptist
and then you go on no rush every day
every day every day
as the fundamentals come to you your
mind will be prepared
to understand the deeper stuff and you
do that
faithfully every day listen to me your
life will change i was in a
certain country on the face of the earth
and i was talking to young people
i recommended this they were 13 year old
14 and you you make that recommendation
without a lot of hope it will be
followed
not even among the 50 year olds and i
went back to the united states came back
several weeks later i got an email
a young man said said pastor you don't
remember me i was in that 13 year old
group you spoke to recommended
the gospel of john he said i have begun
to do it i want you to know i
am a different person now that's a 13 14
year old boy
in an age of facebook and instagram
and snapchat and whatsapp and what's
happening
you know in that age he said i
am a different person
i met a family in south korea
a few years ago a husband and wife two
little boys one three one four they're
probably
five and seven or something like that oh
six or six and eight
i told her i'd like to see you raise
your children for god that she always
wanted to she wanted to buy them so it
wasn't my recommendation i just seconded
the motion
i said do not let them watch television
at
all no 3abn god bless them
no adtv god bless them and i pray for
those ministries
i said if 3abn has something you think
is worthwhile
you watch it learn it
turn it off then you teach it to them
do not turn on the television
for any earthly reason
do not play a radio in your house
give them the bible whatever they can
get from ella white
and take them outside
the birds the trees the grass the little
stream
the father doing his agricultural work
let that be the education
and i said for you study god's word so
they have a spiritual instructor
i gave her the gospel of john i said
pursue it like a course assignment
she got a notebook date february 22
195 2015 john 1 1-4
then she wrote down her observation she
would send them to me
she did that for a year and a half
finish the gospel of john then i said
well let's stick with john go do first
john 5 chapters same thing
sending me regular reports that really
gave me sermon ideas
when she was done she said pastor i'm
finished now she's on
uh
and she is fascinated read her gear
several times
fascinated verse by verse taking notes
and i told her
keep your notes five years from now go
read them again
and see what you learn now she's been
doing the same with her boys teaching
them the word
she sent me a recordings a few months
ago of a five-year-old boy
reciting the book not a recording an
email
he just finished memorizing the book of
daniel
five you know why he could do that
he does not watch television he does not
hear the radio
all he hears is the word spoken by his
mother
eloise writings and the sounds of the
birds
and the stream and the breeze
so all his influences are designed to
make his mind
receptive to the world then she sent me
a recording of him
he did not realize he was being recorded
he was taking a bath you know
five-year-old can handle that
and he started to preach in the bathroom
so the mother and the other children
recorded him five
and she's and he's in the bathroom and
he said romans chapter nine verse four
and the bible says and i'm listening
this little boy he's five
but what is going on is this his mind
has been protected
[Music]
i'll tell you something else i told her
some of you may not like
is there a back door over here no okay
any policeman no
i told her do not allow your children
to mingle with badly trained children in
the church
in the church first i didn't say clearly
let me say it again
i told her do not let your children go
to the homes of
or let those children come to your house
who are badly raised
because they will corrupt your children
now all she feeds them
is the word ellen white and nature
i told her do not put your child in a
public school
i have no children who am i telling
people how to raise their children
but the results are beautiful now in
that process she got pregnant had a
third child
and i sent a rebuke i said you don't
need more children don't get any more
but they know i love them and the both
the father and the mother said okay okay
pastor no more no more
the more children you have the less you
can give to god
okay now you're sleeping listen to me
the more children you have
the less you can give to god
the less time for god because you're
burdened with children
or so many 9 10 12 year olds now this
third child was a girl
but before she was born i told the
mother let the little boys develop
responsibility for her
let them come at night in your room and
sing and read the bible to your womb
read the bible to their sister she knew
by then it was a little girl
and they would come and do that they'd
come and read to the mother's belly
now studies have shown a baby can
recognize the voice of the father
outside the womb
may recognize the sibling i don't know
but they did that now the little girl is
18 months old
and her special gift is music when the
mother takes her out and the birds sing
she develops tunes to harmonize with the
birds
so one little boy has daniel he's a
preacher the other little boy
he has memorized chapters of job
so one little boy he makes spiritual
connections the other one
he can just bring the words to memory
this little girl 18 months old she
develops
songs when she hears the birds now why
because all they know is this
and only god knows if time permits what
those children will become
and i write all the time sister do not
give up raising children is not easy but
it's not required do not give up
ask god for the power he will give you
keep them from the influences keep them
because ellen white says
children raised that way are quick to
recognize the voice of god
because they're not they don't they
don't have all the static of the world
in their minds
they are quick to recognize the voice of
god
i said all of this to say this to you we
are children in the eyes of god
god wants to raise us on this
and nothing else of course as his people
he's given us the counsel of
ellen white please
please let eloise writings be part of
your watch
and prayer listen to me carefully if you
do not
believe in eloise prophetic gift don't
try to spread your disease
keep it to yourself
let others be blessed by reading her
words
are you with me and so i want it
publicly recorded in heaven
i have urged you let the writings of
ellen white
be a part of your life and your
children's lives
now the appeal is long overdue five
after something
how many of you will say father i will
try to take at least so you can increase
the
figure 10 minutes in the morning 10
minutes at night can i see your right
hand honestly honestly any hand you want
to raise
if you mean it stand up
you have just entered into an agreement
with god
now you have to try to keep your word
is god understanding yes he remains he
knoweth our frame he remembers that
we're just psalm 103 verse 14.
we're dust we wake we fall but make sure
god can see
it is in your heart to do it
that's where god's judgment begins in
the heart
in the morning at night
one of the recommendations i don't care
how old you are try to memorize some
bible verses
you will be shocked how god will bless
your effort
one of the story young lady wrote me
several years ago maybe six seven years
ago seeking spiritual counsel
and uh i said part of
spiritual growth and change is the word
of god is the major component he said
why don't you try memorizing some of
god's word she said i can't do it
so i wrote back and said never say i
can't do it say i have not yet done it
because when you say i can't do it it's
recorded
and as a man think of in his heart
so say i have not yet done it
so you recall somebody that has
expectation i urge her she decided to
try gave her
third john 14 verses when she got to
verse 5 she emailed me
excited she said i can't believe
i've memorized the first five verses
excited and i smiled to myself
i said keep going she finished third
john uh
third yeah 14th verse i gave a second
john 13 verses
i gave her john 14 revelation 15 just
eight verses and i give
chapter after chapter she just knocked
them off
then she said to me my life is changing
completely because i'm so absorbed in
memorizing and reciting
that all day at work as i work i recite
what i know and i try to memorize what
i'm trying to learn
then i said to her you've learned all
these individual chapters let's start
with the book i gave her the book of
jonah
four little chapters she finished the
book
then she hadn't reported to me in
several months of her
reciting and memorized memorization so i
wrote to her
she wrote me and she said am i still
special to you i said no
but i will re-re
promote you back to that position as
soon as you tell me about your
memorization she said listen
i started the book of joel i'm in
chapter two
that's last week what am i saying to you
you can do the same thing
there's a lady in a certain country she
has four children youngest one is about
17.
and i urge her please start to memorize
and she started she's busy as an
executive secretary busy woman
husband's big executive somewhere some
big company always flying around the
place
she has memorized chapter chapter chaps
she finished first john
she did the book of james now she's
knocking off a haggai
i told her i'm doing haggai so she did
haggy now this is a woman's children who
you think would be busy but she has
committed herself
that's the problem try
use the king james version start small
start with john 11 35 what does that say
jesus wept
towards
the ellen white writes mind carton
personality volume 2
page 601 paragraph 4 that which at first
seems difficult
by constant repetition grows easy
we call that practice makes perfect
you know why michael jordan shot the way
he shot or larry bird or whomever or
kobe bryant
because every day they would shoot
hundreds of jump shots
every day i was in south africa speaking
to a guy who used to be a professional
golfer
and he said every day i'd hit 600 balls
to perfect my drive
so that the movement became just
automatic the muscles memorized the
movement no need to think
you just did it now
as you try to memorize god's word it
will become
easier you know your telephone numbers
you know where you live
you know every left turn right turn to
get to your house ladies
you can find everything in your closet
with your eyes closed
you've memorized a map of your closet
well just take that ability to god's
word
you take a young boy young girl they
honor all the lyrics the lyrics to the
songs by lady gaga
and beyonce and uh nicki minaj
and who are the others uh lady gaga and
her cousin yes you know
uh give me a man usher
and uh he is he too old give me some
fella i don't know uh
chris brown jay-z
he's about 100 years old so somebody
else and you they
know the lyrics but can't give your
bible first
they know every member of the lakers
basketball team
can't name three pioneers
are you an adventist yes
all right let me let you go my brothers
and sisters
what was the theme for this weekend
watch
and pray you watch not with these
you watch with that what
helps us to watch the word of god
i'll ask you one more time will you in
the presence of a holy god make a
commitment
time in the morning time in the evening
for god's word can i see your hand again
hands down final call is this someone
listening to me
who has drifted far from god
you'd like to come back listen to me
carefully
you have drifted far
you still come to church the devil comes
with you
but you have drifted far
you want to come back because the longer
we drift
the less likely it is we will come back
i ask again
if there's someone listening to me you
have
drifted from god
if that applies to you if so i'm not
talking to all of you
and you want to come back conscious
decision
and god will never make the decision for
you you must make it he will bless it if
you want to come back from that drift
if it applies can i see your right hand
if it applies to you you've drifted come
i'm going to pray for you sis to come
my handsome brother come i'm going to
pray for you you have
drifted from god come
what's your name and another lovely name
ann marie
drifted
come before the devil takes your life
god bless you god bless you my good
brother god bless you
drifted god bless you god bless you
anyone else
you know in your heart you have drifted
god bless you somebody else
you came for baptism nice to see you
come again to renew it god bless you my
good brother
drifted from god come
in december 25 christmas will be here
but let me tell you something more
definite than christmas
christ is coming and he's coming
not to prepare people he's preparing
them now
the choices you make listen to me the
safest
most blessed life to live is a life
lived with a man called jesus
and so he tells us in matthew 11 28 come
unto me
you come to christ first not a church
now he'll take you to a turkey but you
come to him he said come
unto me only that labor and a heavy lady
you've got burdens in your life you've
got addictions you've got struggles
jesus says come to me i
will give you rest and he cannot lie but
he says take my yoke upon you
and learn of me
for i am meek and lowly in heart and ye
shall
find rest unto your souls now you can
stay away from work and find rest for
your body
only god can give you rest for your soul
where your mind is at peace nothing is
perfect but your
mind is at peace you're free from the
cancer of guilt
there's a man who's also god who can do
that
his name is jesus come to me and you
come to christ
by obeying his word anyone else i have
drifted from god
i want to come back come
come with your feet but come at your
heart
god loves you individually that's why
the parable of the lost sheep watch
matter of you having 100 sheep
if you lose one of them doth not leave
the 99 in the wilderness and go after
that which was lost
until you know the words of malcolm x by
any means necessary
god wants to save you by any means
necessary up to and including the death
of jesus
we want to pray let's kneel
dear god in heaven my father
our father i ask you
firstly god if i preach badly forgive me
if i said anything i should not have
said
because i have the fleshly nature
forgive me
if in anything that god i exalted myself
forgive me god
you know my heart is always to lift up
the word
and to call people to obey you that's my
heart
now father i thank you for your
forgiveness
and i present to you those sons and
daughters of yours who answered the call
the call was i have drifted
father in the name of jesus who shed his
blood for them
and somehow you suffered with jesus to
save them
grant them your spirit their god they
need a
measure of your spirit that will sustain
them in this decision
because the devil will try to take them
back
but let them not meditate on the devil
or dwell on him
let them dwell on the source of power
not the source of threat
so give them strength father let them
say like ruth
and treat me not to leave thee or to
return from following after thee
for without goest i will go with our
largest
i will lodge thy people shall be my
people and thy god my god
without diest i will die and there will
i be buried give
them that mind let them say like jacob
in genesis 32 verse 27 i will not let
thee go
except thou bless me
give them that determination they got
let them say
you said come unto you and i will
deliver you then
let them expect that deliverance their
god beginning right now
in the name of jesus who cannot lie
fill them with your spirit a god change
their minds
let them now begin to love the things
they used to hate
and hate the things they used to love
and father let their decision be so
powerful
that those who know them family and
friends
will notice the difference and be
inspired
deal with them as individuals their god
because our needs differ as our faces
our struggles are different so you bless
them
individually take care of them their god
protect them
remember those who should have come but
did not in mercy
go after them father give them no rest
until they come to the savior as we end
watch and pray father let us just be
another step in our journey towards you
growing in grace in christ's likeness
preparing for the coming of your son
but dear god let us not think he's
coming in 10 years let us so live today
that
if we die tonight we shall be safe
in jesus bless every man woman boy and
girl dear god
bless every family under the sound of
your manservant's voice
bless the central filipino church and
the leadership that permitted this
meeting
bless the organizer chris angela and her
team did god let these meetings be the
means by which
many people have been drawn close to you
and as we travel post an angel to go
with
every one of us that we may have a
heavenly escort
to take us safely father i personally
thank you for the high honor
of being a part of this weekend continue
to use me for your glory and your glory
alone
when you come there god save us without
losing one
i pray for my heart in jesus name and
for his sake
let god's people say amen and amen god
bless you
you